what the administration does is lie
about everything and it's not just joe
who often is lying or just confused
right
there's also this kamala harris woman
again this is a woman who was polling at
zero in her own party she got the vp
nomination because she's a black woman
that's what joe said himself don't call
me a racist uh here's what she tweeted
out a day or two ago she said since
january of last year the economy has
added more than eight million jobs
businesses have reopened their doors
schools are back in person and while
there is more work to be done we have
made real progress in getting our
economy back on track now this is a
complete
lie this is a complete lie
and here's cnbc
debunking
that very lie the economy and this is an
important point hasn't added one single
job from the 2019 high watermark not one
all the jobs that we have seen gained
are recovered jobs that were lost we are
not yet producing new jobs in fact we're
still about nearly four million jobs
short
you get that that's the difference
between recovered jobs and new jobs
right recovery jobs and adding jobs
kamala said we added jobs no because if
you went back to 2019 when the economy
was chugging along and things were going
real well and there was this orange guy
what was his name again it started with
the t sort of the t uh trump this trump
guy was president remember him with the
crazy hair and everything and he was
always eating mcdonald's and with the
ketchup and the well done steak that guy
was president things were going great
and then of course kovid came and then
the democrat riots and all that other
stuff
so kamala is lying we did not add more
you can't just if you just wipe out 8
million jobs and then you get those 8
million jobs back that's not adding jobs
that's just getting back what you wiped
out that is what you did there so even
cnbc is debunking the absolute lies of
kamala harris